hello everyone and welcome back to the
chess 24 uh
legends of chess tournament and here we
have a very nice game that i knew i was
gonna show as soon as i saw the second
move on the board and uh well
uh you of course know what i mean due to
the thumbnail uh so without further ado
let's check it out true legends of the
game vasily vancouver and peter lecko
let's see what's happening here uh so uh
we have e4
sorry about that uh by chookie and
e5 we have f4 uh eventually goes for the
king's gambit
and aleko accepts we have e captures on
f4 we have knight to f3
and now there are millions of options
here well not millions but a lot of
options here a lot of defenses for black
that were
considered that are still being
considered the g5 very popular d5 very
popular d6 very popular
however lego goes for h6 it's a very
rarely played defense called the
becker's defense and it kind of prepares
g5
uh so black black just wants to keep
everything here uh and
probably thinking that uh vasili
is not all that uh well versed in this
particular line
so d4 uh you usually want to grab the
center when your opponent doesn't so now
uh we have immense control of the
central squares here and
g5 now uh however uh vasily continues in
the spirit of the king's gambit and goes
to g3 continues
uh opening lines so we have f captures
on g3 and now
h captures on g3 uh had this been morphe
uh probably we'd see something like
bishop to c4 trying to give up yet
another pawn but
this is uh 2020 so we will not see all
that many uh
pawn sacrifices so h captures on g3 and
now
bishop to g7 just continuing development
uh we have knight to c3 and d6 now not
allowing any e5
anytime soon and the disposition has
been reached once before in 1999 in the
russian championship alexander grisham
headed against lunev
uh where bishop the c4 was played but uh
sorry bishop to c4 was played but here
uh vasily goes for bishop to e3 and it
is as of move eight that we have a
completely new game
so uh let's see how lekko deals with
this we have knight to f6
a continuing development and queen to d2
uh here of course white wants the castle
queen side so knight to g4 going after
that strong dark square bishop but
bishop back to g1 not allowing this
trade so
knight to c6 again continuing
development and here we have a queen
side castle we have
a kingside castle by lego not afraid of
uh
of this position really uh being
expanded
here on the king's side and uh he says
i'm just very solid here
and if this was some sort of a classical
game with probably seeking to be one
a nice prophylactic move and only then
starting the attack
but this is rapid chess and vasily says
it's time to strike right away so
knight's the h2
uh here uh saying that uh either he will
trade here or
if a knight captures then he already
gets his rook on h2 because at some
point he wants to make a rook lift and
bring this rook over to h1 so
it works both both ways uh lekko decides
to trade here we have knight captures
rook captures and now bishop to g4 a
nice developing move on the rook
uh well you could block then you invite
a queen d7 and you just
allow a more natural developing plan for
black so so rook to e1
just moving the rook and knights to e7
now the knight is coming to
the g6 where it will help out with the
defense of the king so bishop g2
and now queen to d7 defending the bishop
also preparing to bring this rook into
the game
with bishop to e3 now and knights the g6
as planned then now rook e to h1
and now there's a lot of pressure here
on the king side there's the queen the
bishop just attacking here
the two rooks doubled up and at some
point you are hoping to get this bishop
somewhere probably
somewhere through f1 to d3 and bring it
over to this diagonal
and white will have a very nice
attacking setup so here we have c6 by
lego he just continues development takes
away
these two squares from the white knight
next probably will bring the rook into
the game
and here we could see a lot of a lot of
interesting moves we could see a nice
knight maneuver here going after the
bishop we could see a nice prophylactic
king to b1
a lot of options here however uh
vasily goes for rook captures on h6 and
it's such a
such a lovely idea just giving up the
exchange to change the character of the
game he wants to keep on attacking
he will be up upon so it's not not all
that bad so
uh lego captures and we have rook
captures uh we have king to g7
now preparing to grab the rook and
bishop captures on g5 so white is
attacking he's up upon but
down the exchange and now f6 a very
strong move by lekko creates an escape
route for the king
uh and also takes care of the e5 square
so white will have some problems playing
e5 also
the bishop is now under attack so bishop
back to e3
and now rook to h8 of course aleco wants
to trade down he's up material
so it's only natural to want to trade
down with b3
uh uh just uh making an escape route for
the king
uh so you don't have any background
weaknesses and now rook captures an h6
bishop captures with
check and king the h7 now and here
bishop to f1 now as the king lands on h7
the bishop wants to
get to d3 to grab hold of this diagonal
and you are very happy with your bishop
being defended here
uh black is a material however with the
king being
so loosely placed on h7 it's not all
that clear
so bishop to h3 uh trying to trade off
one of uh
vasilis attackers and now bishop to e2 i
i thought bishop to d3 uh was the way to
go i don't
uh really understand bishop to e2 i'm
sure there's like some sort of a plan
maybe bring it over here or something
maybe maybe try and lock out the the
light square bishop if the queen moves
so i guess it's sort of a waiting move
uh but i don't have any any exact uh
ideas of why bishop to e2 as the bishop
does belong here on d3
so here rook to e8 uh putting pressure
on this pawn and now king to b2 just a
much safer square for the king we have
b5 now
preparing b4 to dislodge the knight away
from here and then
just pick up the e4 pawn and only now
bishop to d3
so first bishop e2 only then bishop to
d3 i'm sure there's a reason somewhere
i just didn't didn't spot it uh and here
we have queen to g4
going after the g3 pawn uh we have
bishop back to e3
and now comes the b4 finally dislodging
this knight we have knight to d1 and
queen captures on g3 so leko grabs this
pawn
but he gives up the b4 pawn on the queen
side so queen captures on b4
uh and here we have uh bishop to g4
attacking the knight on d1
and it's a really tough position for
whites to be in
unless uh unless you're vasily van chuk
and you find
the winning move uh for white so feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find
the absolute best move for white uh
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting uh
well we could call it a talmud we could
call it a a
whatever you want but it is a vasily
vancouver that played it so here for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's e5 and it's such a wonderful move
it just
uh gives up the the knight on d1 the
problem with
capturing the knight on d1 right away is
that you have queen b7
check and now black has a lot of
problems the this cut
the bishop covers this square so you
can't move the king here uh if you if
you block with the root then just
captures the
the knight is pinned there's no
capturing there so after this queen b7
check you'd have to go
somewhere along the back rank let's say
rook hate but now just queen captures on
c6
you attack the rook here and once the
rook moves now you have this queen h1
check for example
uh checking the king and winning back
your bishop so it's a queen h4 you're
gonna pick up the
the bishop and now you're still down the
exchange but with the bishop
pair and the the black king so uh wide
open
it will be an impossible game to play
for black
so instead uh after this e5 move lego
decides to play f5 he closes the light
square bishop's diagonal but now
uh we have queen captures on d6 and now
all of a sudden uh white
created this beautiful past e pawn he's
gonna capture on c6
and you know things aren't looking all
that great for laco
so bishop captures on d1 what is uh
uh white's plan now he's down uh now
he's down a full rook if
if you look at it now he was down the
exchange but now with the sacrifice
piece he is down a full rook so just
bishop captures on f5
nicely threatening the knight here and
of course if you capture another piece
then you're just getting a checkmate
check you have to move and then this is
just made so of course the bishop uh
this must be defended so here rook to g8
and now now we have bishop back to d2
just uh
getting the bishop out of harm's way and
uh
you you are down a whole rook but uh
vasily doesn't care
uh and he says okay lekko it's your move
so let go brings back the bishop he
wants the trade of course but now comes
uh queen to e7 with
check playing the absolute best moves
this is just uh crazy so the knight is
pinned the queen cannot be captured
bishop guarding this here you can see
the the full power of the of the bishop
pair from hell and the problem is let's
say rook
king h8 you're getting made just queen
f6 check king h7 queen f7 check rook can
block
but now bishop captures here uh neither
the the king or the rook can capture
king moves queen f8 check you're gonna
go here and now this is just checkmate
so
after queen e7 check you have to block
with the rook but now
uh now it's just queen to g5 and now
uh instead of uh blacks successfully
trading of the bishop you are just gonna
win
win a piece here so queen h2
uh saying that okay if the queen
captures at least i can capture here
uh but now uh we have just bishop
captures on g4
and okay black still up the exchange but
the bishop player from hell is here the
the past e pawn
and with the black king being so wide
open uh it's
very very hard to play this 97 from
lekko opening up a double attack here uh
but queen to h5 check now it's just a
matter of technique
you trade down into an end game you're
still down the exchange but
three extra pawns will do quite nicely
so rook g2 attacking the bishop bishop b
for now attacking the knight and it is
quite
uh the most precise way knight d5 and
now just
bishop f3 with a double attack here rook
to f2
captures captures and now it's a bishop
against rook but three extra pawns so
bishop c5
and now just preparing to push the pawns
on the queen side with a6
and b4 preparing a4 and b5
so king to g6 lego has to shift the king
all the way to the queen side to try and
survive this
but a4 we have king f5 and now b5
uh a captures a captures the past b pawn
has been created now white has two past
pawns
king to e7 with b6 and now king to d7
and king b3 now preparing to bring the
king also into the game
king c6 and now c4 getting rid of that
uh last pawn so d
captures king captures and now rook to
f4 preventing d5 as the pawn is now
pinned but now
e6 so uh one of one of the three pawns
is definitely
going somewhere we have rookie four leko
puts the rook behind the past pawn but
e7 that pawn is nicely protected now
king d7 but now
even b7 with king to c7 and now
for the last time feel free to pause the
video and find the quickest way to win
the victory uh while i give you a couple
of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
being an excellent spotter of tactics in
an end game and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's bishop
to d6
check a final sacrifice to end the game
and
before i show you why this is winning uh
i will take this moment to award uh
vasili ivanchuk with a nice morphe head
for this
spectacular attacking game and
well now it's just lost because if you
capture the bishop this pawn queens
and if you don't if you go for the pawn
then the point of this bishop check was
bishop e5 the rook no longer guards the
e8 square
and on the next move the pawn is
queening and that's just game over
so uh the funny thing is the lekko was
leading the match up until the fourth
game this is game four
and uh vasily had to go all out to win
the game and he did
with none other than the king's gambit
uh
and then of course they went into the
armageddon however it was peter leko who
won the armageddon game
uh and thus the match uh but they are
they are each awarded uh
uh uh vasil is also awarded a point as
if you just reach armageddon
then you don't just you know lose the
match and get zero points you you
are awarded one point for reaching
armageddon so
quite uh quite the development uh and
quite the game i
i do hope you enjoyed it and we're gonna
show some more games and then we're
gonna discuss about the standings
as i don't know if i will be able to
cover any more games from round one
but in case i will i don't want to spoil
like the the results just yet
so yeah that's the game i do hope you
enjoyed it nice uh
morphe-esque game by vasily vanchuk or
was it maybe a nice mr barnes game we
still have to think about that
uh however i would like to thank
mccarthy fitch
uh harry mackenzie gerald rosen juan
castro sumeta
and mcduff hughes for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the chess 24 legends of
chess tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and uh whatever else happens
in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day